i've actually been going to open mics a
lot recently just listening for
psychological
examinations for people
no i i it's actually really inspiring to
me uh to see people
that you know some are funny some are
not so funny
unapologetically trying yeah putting it
all out there night after night
like eating [ __ ]
yeah my favorite is when
you know you're talking about like five
people in the audience
and the the jokes are just not landing
and they still
i don't know it feels like even just
empathetically
there's few things as difficult as that
it's hard
i still remember these days
many comics will say this and i think
dane cook was the first person i heard
say it publicly that if he ever had to
go back and do it again like from
scratch he doesn't think he could do it
doesn't think he could endure
the struggle of open mic
to
you know ultimately to success and the
numbers of people that try it and fail
versus try and succeed are off the
charts
i don't know if there's any other art
form that has such a low rate of success
because it's psychological it's torture
it is torture and it's also not
something you can learn
like here's the thing like if you uh you
play guitar
you can learn to play guitar
someone can teach you the chords and if
you do it you could you could do uh all
along the watchtower you could play it
you can't teach someone how to do comedy
you think it's you're funny or not or
can you
can you still figure it out like can you
still learn you can figure it out yeah
can you start on fun can you start being
unfunny yeah and become funny yes it's
possible it's not easy though you're
gonna have to eat a lot of [ __ ] you're
gonna have to eat a lot of [ __ ] and
you're gonna have to examine why you're
not funny and you're gonna have to spend
a lot of time with uncomfortable
thoughts
and try to figure out what it is like
what's missing
like you know and could could you edit
your stuff and make it better
maybe you need to do drugs maybe you
need to get involved in psychedelic
drugs and rethink the way you interface
with reality itself maybe you need your
heart broken
maybe you need to be in love maybe
there's a lot of maybes there like maybe
you just need more life experience but
you know when i started comedy i was 21
and i was a [ __ ] i had no information
you know i i i could do impressions of
people and i could talk about sex yeah
those are the things that i was
interested in back then i mean if i was
talking philosophically i didn't have a
i didn't have a philosophy i didn't have
a
unique perspective on life i hadn't
experienced much
so every time you bomb it forces you to
introspect to ask questions to yourself
and then that's how you actually develop
a philosophy yeah what you actually
believe you learn
through doing and i think you could say
that about podcasting too yeah you know
i'm certainly way better at having
conversations than i ever was when i
first started doing comedy or excuse me
when i first started doing podcasts you
learn stick with a kid because one day
you'll be able to interview donald trump
you'd be mad enough
to handle that conversation
um how hard is it to do because i've
been really curious that uh
it's been on my bucket list because i'm
terrified i want to do everything i'm
terrified of stand up no but i do want
to do
like one
five five minute like open mic why you
do kill tony how hard is it to do five
minutes would you say it's hard
well it depends on you know how long
you've been thinking about doing comedy
it depends on how you look at things and
also depends on your style of comedy
like the most difficult style of comedy
is like i think like steven wright style
is probably the most difficult style of
comedy complete non-sequiturs one
subject doesn't lead into the next
there's no flow to it it's just i
noticed this i noticed that and then
there's this and then there's that and
that that's hard to memorize and it's
really hard to piece together uh an hour
of non-sequiturs but it's easier because
you can rely on the joke
it sits more with the joke
like whether you're funny or not is on
the on on the actual material versus
like the timing and the the energy the
dance with the audience right because
like if you don't have the raw jokes
like stephen wright does or mitch
hedberg
um then you have to it's all about the
delivery yeah and yeah that they either
kill or they bomb
is it random like were they killer bombs
yeah
well in the beginning i mean you're
essentially a different person every day
of your life you know you're
similar
but you're more tired
you're more rested you're exhausted
you're refreshed you have vitamins and
food nourishment in your system you just
get your heart broken you haven't slept
in days you're a different person all
the time and you go on to that stage
you know you're in the neighborhood of
who lex friedman is you're in the lex
friedman neighborhood which lex friedman
am i gonna get yeah you know energy
levels yeah it depends it all depends
but oh the other thing with kill tony
is it's videotaped it's yes so you
eating [ __ ] is on there forever forever
the world can see it but it's one of the
most important shows in combat it's the
most important show in comedy because
first of all it establishes
stand up
in a sense that like for the open micros
for the people that are starting it out
it establishes that the most important
thing is to be funny like this is what
the art form is all about and there's a
lot of insecurity attached to that a lot
of fears and so to alleviate some of
those insecurities and fears people will
decide that the message is more
important and they'll pretend that you
know like you have to have like uh
you you have to have
you have to be
socially aware that you have to promote
things that are positive in your comedy
which is [ __ ] there are the people
that say that they're all bad they're
all bad at comedy and that's where the
insecurity is it's like they can't just
kill so they have to pretend that
they're supposed to be socially aware
and that being socially aware is an
important part into society like let me
explain something really clearly it's
not a [ __ ] person on earth who's ever
changed their life because of a joke
that's not what they're there for
they're there for jokes the people that
say that
they s what they say that socially
important comedy is the only comedy
that's necessary the only comedy that
you have to do that is just because they
suck yeah that is it it's like the
cop-out is that they can't do the real
comedy they can't crush it's not like
someone goes from being
you know take a like shane gillis one of
the best comics up and coming right now
he's [ __ ] fantastic i can't recommend
enough seeing that guy live i work with
him in irvine and i hadn't seen like his
whole set i was crying i mean he's so
good i heard he's a racist
i haven't listened to any of his
material no
he's so good and his comedy is
just all just trying to be as funny as
possible
there's not a chance in hell that guy's
just gonna go woke and he's just gonna
start promoting some sort of you know
socially conscious agenda that's you
know facetious and just a bunch of
nonsense that he's trying to elevate his
own personal brand and virtue signal
that's not going to happen
the thing about kill tony is
in that because you only have one minute
and because it's live and because you
don't want tony [ __ ] on you
everybody else sitting on everybody's
just gearing up to try to be as funny as
possible and no one cares if you are gay
or straight or asian or black or trans
or non-binary nobody gives a [ __ ] are
you funny if you're funny you're in and
everybody loves you you could be 80 you
could be 20. nobody gives a [ __ ] you
could be a woman or a man or ambiguous
nobody [ __ ] cares are you funny and
that's the most important thing for a
community of comedy to
really promote comedy just funny just be
funny and
so in that sense kill tony is a real
cornerstone of comedy it's a reminder
what comedy's supposed to be yeah that
said even the funniest like the funniest
stuff
has underneath it some wisdom sure comes
out of it but that's not the the primary
goal of it yeah i mean it might be
tiring and fun oh tim dillon's a great
example of that yeah
he's got some amazing insights in his
comedy but still
it's all about [ __ ] comedy it's all
about the funny yeah it's always funny
he's got he's the best at doing that
especially in a podcast form about
weaving like really important points in
with hilarious you know obviously
just you know
just jokes
you